and with us now with more as judicial
watch president tom Fitton Tom I can't
say this enough the work of Judicial
Watch has been critical in this you have
gotten more information they actually
had a strategy as I read these documents
all rod was gonna say oh he was just
joking when he said that what to deflect
from what the truth was that they were
talking about it exactly right this is
the first official confirmation based on
government documents the discussions
took place their allegations that took
place there was some testimony about it
but here you have rod Rosenstein and his
team trying to craft a response
non-denial denial to the allegations and
when you look at the materials you see
Rosenstein saying that hey you know
we're hopeful we're successful in
preventing people from talking about it
they changed the statement from a
categorical denial rod Rosen Stein's
direct statement from a categorical
denying that discussions about the 25th
amendment did not take place to a less
categorical denial so you have this
confirmation that a they were talking
about the 25th amendment be quote he was
sarcastically talking about wearing a
wire in the president United States and
you have to remember Shawn those
discussions involve three topics wearing
a wire invoking the 25th amendment and
what else
appointing a special counsel and we know
the special counsel was appointed Wow
all right Tom that's all part of the
same scheme Shawn unbelievable
breakthrough discovery yet again by Tom
Fenton Judicial Watch